- [Voiceover] Do you wanna bang tonight?
(doorbell rings)
- Oh hey, can you stay
the fuck in your room?
- I'm pretending like I
wasn't frantically cleaning
for the past 15 minutes.
- I tried on seven outfits
before I decided on this one.
- [both] Bullshit about wine.
- I've been wine tasting once.
Diverting this nervous energy
by looking at a screen.
I'm putting the burden of choice on you.
- Oh I'm not accepting
that responsibility.
- Then that case I will
offer up five or six
very diverse choices to
show my intelligence,
sense of humor, the fact
that I went to college.
- Comment about that really popular series
everyone's talking about on the internet.
- Yeah.
- [both] But starting a series together
is a lot of commitment.
- Who cares, we won't be
watching the movie anyway.
- Oh yes I just wanna make out a lot.
- And do other stuff.
Alright getting ready to
be nervous for 20 minutes
about when to touch you.
- And how we decide to sit now
will determine a precedent
about the rest of our relationship.
- Ignoring the fact that
my arm's gonna be numb
in 10 minutes.
- Oh, too close to your butt.
Oh, too close to your vagina.
Too close--
(gasps)
- I'm not actually scared,
I just wanted to touch your leg.
- Commenting on the movie to start
an overlapping dialogue.
- I'm answering but I know
what you're actually doing
considering how close
our faces are together.
- I'm just kinda talking to talk.
- Angling my face hoping
you're gonna take a hint.
- Hiding my boner with my elbow.
- Hoping you're gonna make a move.
- I still can't tell if you like me.
- Fuck it.
(romantic music)
- I'm eating your cereal.